Dwayne: Alright lets kick this off so everybody
well first of all, welcome and as we say in the islands, aloha
its gonna be amazing night, it's a very very big night.
Its an epic night, we're so proud, we're so excited.
Ladies and gentlemen I want to bring to the stage
Lin-Manuel Miranda, here we go!
Lin: Hello, hello, hello!
Welcome to the premier of Moana you guys
Dwayne: A song that I sing in the movie, it's called
"You're Welcome" and "Thank you"
and it was written by Lin, and I figured since we're here, it's a celebration
Lin: -Oh you want to drop a little "you're welcome" on em'?
a word?!
Dwayne: I think we dropped some "you're welcome"
♪ Hey! What can I say except you're welcome ♪
♪ For the wonderful world you know ♪
♪ Hey, it's okay, it's okay you're welcome! ♪
♪ Well, come to think of it, I gotta go ♪
♪ 'cause I'm gonna need that boat ♪
♪ Hey! I'm sailing away, away ♪
♪ You're Welcome! ♪
♪ 'cause Maui can can do everything but float! ♪
♪ And thank you! ♪
Dwayne: Ladies and gentlemen, we bring out the star
Of Moana
The voice... of... Moana
Ladies and gentlemen,
Lin: Auli'i Cravalho
♪
Lin: Give it up for Auli'i Cravalho!
Dwayne: Wow! Ladies and gentlemen,
Auli'i: Thank you!
Lin: That was amazing!
Auli'i: Thanks guys!
Dwayne: Ladies and gentlemen, welcome to... the world premier of Disney's Moana
Auli'i: Woo!
*percussion music*
*singing*
♪
*crowd noise*
*indistinct photographer instructions and shutter noises*
♪ Aue, aue ♪
♪ Nuku i mua ♪
♪ Te manulele e tataki e ♪
♪ We read the wind and the sky when the sun is high ♪
♪ We sail the length of the seas on the ocean breeze ♪
♪ At night, we name every star ♪
♪ We know where we are ♪
♪ We know who we are, who we are ♪